this is from a place called Gregg's
which I have to assume as is local are
you sure it's not plastic it's rather
hard let's give it a shot
that's pretty edible am I allowed to eat
the whole thing
[Music]
hey man I'm Kevin Smith and this is
snack wars vegan edition 4vw vegan
edition course one lady's joke okay this
is from a place called Greg's which I
have to assume as is local cuz I've
never seen this we don't spell anything
with two G's in the States
let's see what this is it looks like I
don't know I don't know what this is
this is a vegan sausage roll all right
it's are you sure it's not plastic it's
rather hard let's give it a shot
oh my lads eat the whole thing
no I'm gonna be honest with you I was
pretty shitty about Greg's a minute ago
but I'm ready to leave and go to Greg oh
the symbol of America ladies and
gentlemen that's our flag right there oh
well this I know
sash them kids you know I gotta be
honest it is better oh I don't know if
you can see this kids but someone made
these let's pretend we're back in school
and maybe I could trade this with
another student for something far better
you guys want silence so I guess you
never traded good people I don't quite
get that
there's nothing in this world better
than a peanut butter and jelly sandwich
and I've had sex a few times all right
so that's [ __ ] beautiful now this has
brown jelly I never seen that [ __ ] in my
life
holy Christ I mean I might refuse see
this on principle oh no it's vegan
cheese and pickle
I don't eat that [ __ ] in real life oh
yeah that's good
holy [ __ ] man and this is a choice
somebody makes this this wasn't like a
joke for me this rock came about in
jelly all your twin we got some warheads
and we got some swizzles love hearts
let's start with warheads Jason Mewes
the guy plays Jay and Jay and Silent Bob
would eat these all the time back when
he was a heroin addict and he would fall
asleep on my couch while he's eating him
and drool would run out of his mouth
colored like this multicolored drool one
of these menthol Joker extreme shower
survived the sour savor the sweet oh so
I gotta get through a top layer of some
[ __ ] in order to get to the good
stuff inside and that describes America
to a tee well it ain't worth getting to
the sweet man I want to work that hard
I love hearts this one says will you
home oh here we go
now I've heard of these cats this is
either a made-up brand from a movie or
local food just like every drink in
England it is lukewarm they don't have
ice or refrigeration in this country
with its fizzy so it's bubbling smells
okay it's okay I mean you know you can't
really [ __ ] up sugar water and let's see
virgil's I've seen on shelves I've never
tried so I had to come all the way to
England to try this
Oh God
that tastes like a happy childhood right
there that brings back so many memories
man root beer between the two this is
the wind howl didn't we do this like
every day this is amazing
these are called twiglets you can tell
it's local of course I know these man
let's start with these bad boys
it smells like cardboard all right well
there's I know exactly what this is
gonna be the winner is the UK
go figure man can I have the rest that
peanut butter sandwich yeah let's go
I've been having one of those in a long
time you got to try that walk no that
was horrifying
[Music]